apple's m2 ipad pro is coming in just a
couple of months likely in october and
we just got some brand new leaks that
are pointing to both some really good
news as well as some pretty bad news and
it has to do with the amount of money
that you're gonna spend on this new ipad
pro because apple is doing a little bit
of trickery at least that's what it
seems like based on this new leak so
let's jump right in but before we get
into those groundbreaking new leaks i've
gotta talk about something else that's
groundbreaking and awesome our sponsor
propella e-bikes who make lightweight
and affordable pedal assisted electric
bikes complete with compact and
swappable battery packs and an lcd
display to check your speed battery life
and adjust the motor settings and you
can use a coupon code max tech 50 for 50
off using the link below first of all it
has to do with the ipad pro featuring a
new 4 pin smart connector now before i
dig into those details i have to talk
about what we are expecting in terms of
this new ipad pro where back in june
mark german from bloomberg was saying
that apple's developing a redesigned
ipad pro with a glass back
and wireless charging for 2022 in just a
couple of months now i do want to
mention that back in january apple was
said to have hit a roadblock in their
plans to redesign the ipad pro with mac
safe because they had trouble with that
glass back breaking and because of that
some sources were saying that apple
could make an ipad pro prototype that
had a larger apple logo whereas the
whole back isn't glass just the logo
itself so we could kind of pass through
that wireless charging power and that
kind of makes a lot of sense because the
rest of the back is fully metal so it's
nice and strong and sturdy and you just
have the center portion with a larger
apple logo for reverse wireless charging
and whatever else you want to do now
mark german did say once again in march
that max safe charging is likely coming
so it is going to be used some sort of
wireless charging of course with the m2
chip that we already got in the macbooks
and again in june he did confirm that
it's debuting in september or october
and now with this fresh and new report
on the ipad pro it looks like some
things with the whole mac safe wireless
charging could actually be changing
because i did not expect this to happen
apparently the new smart connector is
going to now have four pins instead of
three which is a big deal because it
changes a lot of the other things we
should expect with the ipad pro first of
all because the current three pin ipad
pro smart connector is used to connect
different accessories like the magic
keyboard and the interesting thing is
that the magic keyboard has a
pass-through charging port within the
hinge but one of the things we noticed
when we were testing it was that the
ipad pro charges quite a bit slower when
you're using that port within the hinge
compared to just plugging it into the
ipad pro itself which kind of makes it
disappointing if you know that it's
slower because you definitely want to
use the hinge port because it can't
really pass through data it just passes
through charging and you want to leave
the ipad pro port free for connecting
accessories and whatever else but you're
gonna have slower charging now what this
means is that the new four pin connector
is gonna accept more power which
hopefully it's gonna allow you to get
the same charging speed on both the
hinge port and the ipad pro itself but
unfortunately this means something
totally different if you already have
the magic keyboard case for the current
ipad pro which by the way is very
expensive 300 to 350 dollars just for
this keyboard case with a track pad that
keyboard case is not gonna work on the
new ipad pro no it's not gonna work
because it has four pins compared to the
current one that has three so right away
apple is gonna make you buy a new magic
keyboard case even if you already have
one for your ipad pro despite the source
makatakara saying that the new chassis
for the 12.9 and 11 inch ipad pros are
gonna have the same design the same size
and everything apple is swapping that
pen layout to force you to buy a new
magic keyboard case which is very
unfortunate for people who are trying to
save money but it gets really crazy when
you dig into this new leak and you see
that they also mentioned a second new
smart connector placed on the top of the
ipad pro as well which doesn't make
sense unless you look back at some of
the older leaks which we actually
covered like i made this video eight
months ago there were actually leaks of
a max safe 3 connection on the ipad pro
yes a physical one just like the one on
this macbook pro and the new macbook air
a wired mac safe connector and the crazy
thing is we also had some leaked renders
from many months ago of a four pin
magsafe connector on the bottom of the
ipad pro alongside the smart connector
now that really shakes things up because
i was expecting apple to put in a larger
apple logo on the back for wireless
charging and not the mac safe 3 method
so i'm not sure if they could do both of
those at the same time but it's also
important to note that the max a3
connector has five pins instead of four
so maybe that kind of disregards all of
that or maybe they come up with a new
mac safe with four pins i'm not sure but
i think the wireless method is gonna be
the one that i'm very excited to see and
that's because of this right here as you
can see i made a couple of videos
showing off wireless mac safe charging
where the actual magic keyboard itself
has two charging coils so you can
reverse wireless charge and accept
charge through the max safe magic
keyboard itself like you can see right
over here the mac save puck charging the
ipad pro as well as charging accessories
like air pods right on the back of the
magic keyboard and if you think that's
crazy we actually had a patent from
apple where they had wireless charging
built into the case for the ipad pro and
you can see that right here apple
invents a future version of their magic
keyboard that will be able to recharge
an iphone apple watch and more you can
see the image right here it has the
keyboard it has two coils now of course
it's not going to look like this because
they have different patents that don't
really talk about the design just the
general idea
but the cool thing is you can see right
here a possible future magic keyboard
device for ipad that has a back portion
that could be used to recharge other
devices such as iphone apple watch
airpods case and more using
magnets built into the housing aligning
with the coils which is basically max
safe so with that said i'm not exactly
sure what method apple is gonna go in
terms of max safe charging and what that
new smart connector is gonna mean but i
do think that it shows that we have a
very high chance of apple redesigning
the magic keyboard completely from the
ground up which means that we are more
likely to see wireless reverse charging
mac safe being built into the ipad pro
and the magic keyboard case and as a
bonus that new 4-pin smart connector is
going to probably charge up the ipad pro
faster making the thunderbolt port free
for the other accessories so if you
disagree with me let me know in the
comment section below but if you enjoyed
this video click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
and definitely check out one of those
two right there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]